hi I'm Adam Devine from workaholics and
this is blake anderson ponders home and
we're gonna audition for season four of
Game of Thrones
man I am super horny where is my sister
Plus this is not around my mom will view
where's my mom
my name is Lord a deathly murder Calif
house double cross welcome to my castle
you will be safe here we go at last to
war men ready us wolves and shields yeah
women
so she boobs no reason allow me to
introduce myself I am dong dangle taint
of house plans nice to meet you
and the way meat is spelled is me-80 so
we're talking wieners where we look we
actually don't know there's not real
dragons wish you could you have to hold
up my cat the bottle is nice bring that
crazy redhead chicken so that creepy
smoke monster can come out of Emma China
hello I am your marry half man some call
me jingles the fool while others call me
dwarf jingles still others call me you
know I don't I'm not even that sure I
don't really like this bit I'm 5 foot 8
so a little respect I'm not a dwarf it
has been 5 minutes without any nudity
time for thine it's to the throne dime
sir
[Applause]
Oh yo-yo hey am i late for the wedding
cuz boy what my face be red